in case you guys have been living under
a rock uh we just came back from the
trash taste tour in America oh it feels
so good yeah it feels good it's so good
I had too much America yeah
I I am America doubt yeah you know yeah
I wake up next to City I'm like why'd
you have to be American city God God
[ __ ] damn it I've had I've had enough
of this right now so we did 23 shows
around the entire US 41 days on the road
yeah there's uh yeah a long time went to
a lot of the most populated U.S states
obviously we didn't go to many of the
ones like Nebraska yeah Montana
sorry guys there's not much to do there
yeah like people there sorry Midwest
yeah but we had a lot of people from
those less populated states come to some
of the shows yeah which is cool read
some people Canada like drive down to
some of our like Northern shows and some
people came out from Mexico and stuff
like that as well people from Mexico
Drive up for like Texas we had one
person that we met that flew in from
Hawaii which is holy [ __ ] [ __ ] insane
yeah
that's crazy I mean yeah we had uh so we
had 23 shows we started from uh we did
one tester show in L.A then flew to
Minneapolis and got on the tour bus yeah
which was so much cooler than I think
any of us expected oh it was so cool I I
you know I thought I was kind of like
dreading the tour bus and you know we
got a lot of questions about like what
is that I'm scared for the tour yeah
because I'm just like expecting yeah I'm
going to be leaving with this with these
guys and much of strangers for like 40
days I don't know how I feel about that
but it was actually like really really
nice really really comfortable and a lot
of fun as well yeah
um because it kind of felt like after
the road trip special which is now out
thankfully like I was I was dreading
that it was going to be 41 days of just
that experience and I was like I'm
literally gonna kill one of the boys
stuck in this space but like the tour
bus actually gave you like quite a lot
of space and quite a little like time to
the original I think I think it
definitely helped that the majority of
the traveling that happened on the bus
was happening while we were asleep yeah
so it was like traveling yeah yeah yeah
it was like Fast traveling around PG
it's great because people are asking us
oh how's how's the drive been how's the
roads been and we were like literally I
we we blink in one place and we wake up
in another yeah the only roads I think
we any of us saw we were like the roads
between
um I think Colorado and uh I guess Vegas
and all that stuff and a lot of Nevada
that was the only part I think we were
awake while we were traveling yeah and
even then it was like what an hour or
two in the morning yeah you don't
actually spend a lot of time on the bus
as you think so the normal day would be
you know you wake up you've arrived at
the new place you pretty much
immediately get off the bus so your bed
is like a capsule hotel but stacked and
there's 12 of you yeah
um and then you get off the bus shower
at the venue go get lunch then maybe you
wait around then do sound check at three
yeah you'd have to wait for like an hour
or two then we do the Q a before the
show at six yeah and we wait and then I
finished at seven wait one hour eight
and then we finished the show around 10
10 30. we maybe have a celebration on
the bus yeah we're drinking talking
until like two and then we go to bed and
the bus moves yeah that's kind of every
single day
that was basically our schedule uh our
life was just living on a bus or in a
green room and I like I don't know about
you guys like a lot of people were like
scared about would I get good sleep on
the bus I got [ __ ] fantastic sleeping
I got us better sleep on the bus than I
did in some hotels it was a nice roll
for me some days I did some days I
didn't it was mainly like because I
don't know about you guys but I realized
that sleeping on a moving vessel while I
needed to pee was kept waking me up I
had to go pee like at least two three
times a night and normally normally I
don't ever have to pee when I'm sleeping
right right so this was like oh my God
I'm getting so stressed out how old men
feel yeah I felt like I was I was
rapidly aging yeah but some nights I
would get amazing sleep because the bus
kind of rocks you like it's the engine
hum is so loud and also there's AC in
the sleeping like quarters yeah area
yeah there's a giant AC unit that is so
loud and ventilation system yeah and
then so you cannot hear anything from
anyone else's bunk
um so it was surprised like because
because I remember the first time we got
on this bus and we saw how close of a
proximity all the beds were to each
other yeah I was like oh I don't think
there's gonna be any privacy like I'm
gonna be able to hear everyone [ __ ]
yeah nothing it's literally like in you
know when you fall asleep
it was perfect because even though the
AC in like the engine were really loud
they acted at like the perfect white
noise like if if you've ever like slept
with like a white noise like filter or
something in the background that's kind
of what it felt like where you couldn't
hear anyone snoring you couldn't hear
anyone like rustle around or anything
like that you just heard a constant
white noise that was constant throughout
the night and then I sleep great on
moving vehicles I don't know about you
guys but when the bus I slept better
when the bus was in motion than when the
bus was like still although I must say
our bus driver did get a little wacky
crazy at some of the locations like
there were some turns where he did where
because you're stopping and starting so
much good traffic because the highways
are just you're going yeah but the
city's just stopping and starting so
you're like you know your body's sort of
coming out of the Sleep Cycle anyway and
then you're kind of like
yeah yeah
like wake up a lot earlier than you want
to a lot of the time yeah yeah so like
to explain this bus it was it we call it
a bus it's more like a coach you know
what I mean because when I say when I
say bus I think like double decker bus
no it was like a like a single Decker
like coach kind of thing and then you go
into the you go into the coach and then
the first thing you see is like this
living room area where you've got like a
bunch of you got like sofas on either
side there's a table in the kitchen and
stuff like that
um three TVs scattered all yeah three TV
scattered around permanently playing
[ __ ] SpongeBob or some [ __ ] whatever
was on American TV
um and then you go into the next room
and there are 12 bunk beds and there are
like three three stacks three layers
basically three layers so there's the
bottom layer there's the middle layer
and there's a top layer and according to
like most people you get the best sleep
on the middle layer right so me and
Connor chose the middle layer Joey chose
the top layer yeah which kind of scared
me because if you fall out of that bed
I mean you know I only chose the top
bunk because I'm a child at heart and I
was like oh yeah
but no like you know I I still got
really good sleep on the top it was fine
yeah yeah and then there's one extra
room in the back which was meant to be
for the talent room but that just that
just turned into let's just put all our
shits into this one room yeah and it was
like unusable yeah I guess in like a
normal tour yeah like the the talent
have their own like private quarters if
there's like one Talent apparently some
of the two buses have the like a room
that's like a bedroom as well oh okay
yeah yeah yeah right I mean that would
be cool but yeah yeah and and you know
for the most part like we didn't really
utilize that room and it kind of just
became like a storage space just yeah
because like yeah I mean you know when
when Aaron uh who helped organize the
store shout out to Aaron by the way um
you know was like you know by the end of
this tour these guys who you think are
strange just right now we're going to be
with you on this bus they're going to
end up being like family yeah and like
you know I always thought when I heard
that from like multiple people uh you
know who've done tours before I just
thought it was like you know just some
kind of like you know it's not excuse
type of thing but you know just like I
think that maybe not everyone can relate
to that type of thing right but like I
don't know I don't know about you boys
but like by the end of the tour it was
like a family yeah and we got really
close to the the staff that we had and
we were always just like hanging out
with them in that front section and so
we were like we don't have to use this
background let's just go hang out with
everyone else because obviously you want
to hang out there real yeah you're
always hanging out with everyone this
was a good time so there's actually
there was actually more people than I
thought they were going to be living on
the bus with us like prior to the tour
because we only knew probably we were
gonna have like some Geeks uh Geeks plus
staff members and some people from the
tour company that we worked with and I
was thinking okay that's gonna be like a
manager someone like stagehands I like
didn't take into account just how much
staff is needed to run a tour because
like there's like multiple merch people
and there's like managers and everything
like that
and there's our staff as well on top of
that and you know there's the technical
people as well there were like so many
people on this tour bus with us and I
thought [ __ ] this is this is gonna be a
lot for 41 days but like it was such a
nice experience because luckily everyone
was chill and we pretty much got along
with everyone yeah
um and it was just I don't know you guys
you guys said it kind of felt like a
holiday in some cases yeah it did I I
definitely treat it as a holiday well
yeah because like we I normally work way
more than that so only doing like a
two-hour show and then having the rest
of the day where I can't really do
anything it's kind of like oh okay
because like you know there were some
days where like we had to stop by kind
of halfway between two places because uh
legally our bus driver could only drive
a certain amount of hours per day so
yeah there were some days where we would
stop buying just like the middle of
nowhere get a day hotel and then just
you know go and explore type of thing
and in my head I'm like okay before the
a toll I planned out these days of like
on the days that were at the hotel yeah
we could get like our own room and I
could like you know film something catch
up to work and stuff like that but then
when it actually happened I was like no
I think I'd rather just go out with
everyone and like actually go see this
part of the country that yeah let's be
real probably not going to go back to
yeah we're going to go back like when am
I ever gonna go back to Biloxi
Mississippi yeah you know so [ __ ] we had
a great time there actually
had a great [ __ ] time there